58 seconds of logos but really chapter 1
right because it's a prequel wait it's
chapter 2 because it happens after
insidious chapter 2 which was actually
chapter 1 okay that's a pretty nice
house for someone who's only marketable
school is talking to dead people but if
you're looking for a reading
unfortunately I don't do those anymore
the classic I don't do that anymore
cliche why don't you come in for a
minute at least doesn't do this anymore
but what does she expect will happen if
she invites this girl in they're just
gonna chitchat and then she's gonna
leave
she's obviously determined to
communicate with a dead person so this
doesn't seem like a smart move for
someone who doesn't do that anymore
you're a very smart girl Quinn Oh
dependency to ask no you are you read a
lot you have a lot of books in that bag
of yours for a second there you thought
Elise was being psychic but she's really
just pulling a Sherlock Holmes movie yes
you could say it wanted a beer there
just as much as everyone else did
I think this girl just discovered the
cure for cancer be a super huge asshole
so your cancer won't like you she loved
old music like vinyl records is final
records a band at least needed to turn
off that light because spirits are
frightened of dimly lit lamps Lily are
you out there
if you can just call it two dead people
from anywhere is the reading room
downstairs just for show
I admire help alight Elise's to the
creepy demon at first sorry there's a
reason I had to stop doing this because
she is clearly no good at it every time
she reaches out you find some sickly
demon or some old lady there's other
people that do this you have to find one
of them at least must have terrible Yelp
reviews this girl clearly should have
chosen a meeting and with a higher
rating if you call out to one the debt
all of them can hear you the same is
true for the living let's say I've
enough football game and I call up Josh
at least 17 guys are gonna turn around
mom Quinn calls out to the dead member
of her family before any of the living
ones that are actually in the house with
her yeah doesn't she share a wall with
the neighbor boy why would she assume
any slight noises her dead mother and
not the long list of more rational
things to think there's no food didn't
you go to the grocery clearly no one
lifted a finger to help her poor dead
mom around the house she's still doing
dishes when she had cancer don't want to
say she's better off but I bet the
ghosts realm doesn't smell like mildew
none of what you just said to me makes
any sense
don't be out of touch dad doesn't know
anything cuz he's out of touch cliche
will you just go get your brother ready
for school please is she looking to
contact her mom so she can take over all
the household duties again why are we
experiencing this extreme close-up
around her room
movie is forcing me to violate this
girl's privacy as well as critique her
music taste why is it quiet
quiets not good ironic words he will
come to regret check see this face his
mobile best face when and it looks just
like your normal face
dad just bust through the door of his
teenage daughter's room without knocking
oh good timing Hector
now you get to see Quinn it's the
embarrassing little brother trope
complete with blond hair and smug little
face
PPC now a woman who says crazy things
but will reveal something about the
demon later in the movie cliche holy
we're only fourteen minutes in and they
managed for cliche so far they didn't
want to hire an actor for this part so
they just got one of those cardboard
cutouts and put his hand on a pendulum
which in retrospect may have taken more
effort than just hiring someone to stand
there and wait for two seconds
holy where is this theater Pan's
Labyrinth this is the creepiest theater
in the world right great
Russ dude in charge of auditions to
throw you off your game trope I won't
ever forget this
we don't dishing for theater school
don't prepare a monologue that begins
with I will never forget this if there
is even the slightest chance that you
will forget it what's going on with this
guy cooking it's not a hotdog stand or
anything looks like just some dude
cooking something in a bucket maybe he
lives in an apartment nearby and really
wanted to grill out and didn't have any
of the tools available so he just
improvised why is it in many horror
films the pretty lead is friends with
some punk emo supporting character did
high school kids in this town just hang
out in dirty alleyways with guys cooking
God knows wooden buckets there has to be
a mall somewhere at first he seems
pretty friendly just casually waving
from a distance but I'm not sure what
his goal is here is he trying to
befriend her before he possesses her
seems like it would be easier to just
skip this part
suddenly a magical car operates out of
nowhere making a stock screeching sound
effect on the bright side you probably
won't have to take care of your brother
anymore when she dies she goes to the
reverse matrix it even really screwed up
here if he wanted to take her soul he
had the perfect opportunity but he just
jumped scared her back to life now we
have to go through a standard possession
is that a cliche yes it is an important
character that adds nothing to the movie
but I don't need you pointing on cliche
things also this creepy bedroom is
brought to you by Jack Link's beef jerky
feed your demon side everything you like
books
she likes just books that's pretty
general dad what else is in that basket
oxygen I'm vegetarian well she's in luck
because I'm pretty sure Jack Link's beef
jerky isn't actually me I know this is
supposed to be scary but it's actually
just hitting too close to home that's
exactly how I walk around in the middle
of the night maybe the man who can't
breathe is just looking for his cell
phone charger
this woman has a sad life she takes two
bites of a bologna sandwich in her dimly
lit house that hasn't been updated since
the early 1900s
then goes to be with her husband sweater
vest I cannot believe there's a stamped
leather journal with his exact image
that she uses to write down her vision
did she happen to find this at a very
specific shop one day and throw away her
steno pad you know what book is high on
my list not to read after a traumatic
experience a Clockwork Orange okay she's
going to text Hector who she thinks is
knocking back and he's not going to be
there so we know it's the demon great my
question is if the demon is so evil why
is he waving casually strolling around
the bedroom and properly responding to
shave and a haircut maybe he's just
looking for a friend did dude already
have those composed and was just waiting
to hit Send they came in way too quickly
that's the dangit if I was home I could
have gotten a handjob emoji I'm sending
this reluctantly but it has to be done
she's doing the opposite of what a
normal person would do when they were
just freaked out cliche did he just
reached through the ceiling is that what
is happening here if so he has really
stretchy arms every ghost movie makes me
question the ghost rules
this is corporeal enough to make
footprints but also reach a giant arm
through the ceiling into the room below
tell me he's gonna pay for the crack in
my ceiling no one is even the slightest
bit concerned about the tar footprints
or the fact that his daughter was just
touched by something the ceiling should
be the least of your worries
I think that was mom trying to reach me
you still think it's your mom
we weren't even 5 minutes into this
movie when Elise said point blank no
it's not your mother how old is that
lock I'm pretty sure that was the key
Ben Franklin used to discover
electricity fine I'll help her does
being psychic include dr. Doolittle like
powers did the man who can't breathe
never learn how to properly walk that
looks like an extremely awkward way to
turn left maybe it's the ghost of Derek
Zoolander again what are the ghost rules
is it also a pickpocket who can remove
things from your body without you
feeling it hopefully it's not a pervert
ghost but still Quinn should watch her
bra I know you're not her mother the
standards of telling which ghosts are
and are not Quinn's mother are set
pretty low so I guess it makes sense
that's something this obvious to me can
only be obvious to a psychic in this
universe ah the standard psychic beaded
curtain accessory it must be free with
every purchase that mediums are us I
know you're there is it possible this
demon / ghost isn't aware its leaving
footprints everywhere
ah too late now Elise right the real
villain as always is your internet
provider
anything is scary when it's accompanied
by a group of violinists that are
apparently playing in the back of a
pickup truck that just backfired he can
clearly just appear wherever he wants
but he casually strolls over to the
window to shut the curtains
sounds like they brought in Darth Vader
to provide the sound effect for the
demon you live in an old thin walled
apartment building feel free to scream
and yell and beg for help at any time
kid all that walking around and shutting
things just to yell inner ear I feel
like he and the people making this movie
you're just figuring all this out as
they go along sometimes he leaves behind
black tar footprints other times he
doesn't why you ask because you that's
why okay she is comedic Lee
incapacitated at this point this is poor
girl going to be in a full body cast
drinking from a straw by the time this
demon finishes before I thought that it
was mom trying to contact me it's
something else even though the viewer
knows the demon is real her father does
not but from his perspective his
daughter is still clearly troubled the
point is going to send his grieving
constantly injured maybe self harming
from his POV daughter to a psychiatrist
sure wasn't just a bad dream
I wonder how many bad dreams Quinn's dad
has had that threw him out of bed people
called her the cat lady why did people
call her this she never once had a cat
or talked about cats or looked like a
cat or a sweater with a cat on it or was
named kitty why did we do any of that
scene smoothie does an excellent job at
introducing characters that have no role
in the story I guess without them the
movie would have been too short can we
just make it a rule that no more horror
movies can do long empty hallways The
Shining did long empty hallways they are
all off limits now if someone told me
this was an episode of American Horror
Story hotel I would believe them let's
look at the bright side here it was nice
of him to push her down the hallway in a
wheelchair instead of flinging her
around again this movie was so close to
not containing any needless
objectification but here it is a sexy
demon but it's a reverse Lord Baltimore
so far this demons biggest crime is king
up original hardwood floors alright
let's take a moment here out of does
this work I get it he can walk on walls
but this seems way more complicated than
just jumping through the window did he
step on the wall try to continue walking
but then fell through the window but
that wouldn't work because gravity
doesn't change
maybe he jump from wall and doh through
window you know what I'm gonna stop
trying to inject logic where there
clearly is none so I guess he can
spider-man style crawl up walls too I
guess the jump scare would be a little
less jumpy if he was standing
horizontally off the wall like his
footprints would suggest
that was an amateurish ly abrupt scene
change
did he exclusively wear that sweater
best it must have been strange to go to
the beach with him
imagine the sweater vest Tam actually do
yourself a favor and don't imagine that
I visited the dark looking for him I'm
looking forward to the insidious six
prequel of this gender swap Orpheus myth
something we living people are not
supposed to do I would imagine that we
aren't supposed to do any of it that's
how we maintain the qualification to be
living people
classic Elise being easily persuaded to
go into situations where she would have
to use her talents when you go there
things come back with you is she talking
about Walmart that seems to happen every
time I go to Walmart if we were all
about this being a dark place why would
the dark place provide her with a light
and why would it look like that whoever
does the interior design for the dark
place must be really into Japanese
culture she better be careful walking
down that hallway I remember this part
the elevator opens and some patrons of
Disney's Hollywood Studios ride down the
hall in some sort of hybrid elevator car
before coming to another elevator shaft
for freefall where's the man who can't
breathe
who is it trying to upset him Elise
didn't say that doesn't really answer my
question does the dark place also have a
furniture store does the decor change
with the eras in which the mediums live
is it all in her mind man how insidious
the musical I guess I'm supposed to be
scared of this old lady from the first
insidious movie but since I know how at
least dies and it's not during this
moment who cares I can't believe they
got jared leto to play this old woman
how many times can she not help the
repetition here is staggering
we are almost two-thirds into this movie
we haven't spent any time with a little
brother until now he was a lazy little
and he was gone and now he's all cleaned
up and assertive I think even the
non-religious people would give a priest
a call before hiring these guys
shouldn't that one where you guys get
the ghost out of that one hotel wasn't
that the plot of ghostbusters I know
these guys are phony if they were real
ghost hunters they would be able to tell
but the icing on this cupcake has some
supernatural power because it keeps
disappearing she says one day
I'm going to die by her hand demons are
not into spoiler alerts I gift us all a
half it's all yeah okay you're more than
one thing my dice told me so I feel like
Elise could have avoided a lot of
heartache if she'd said to Quinn at the
beginning of the movie I don't do that
anymore but my friend Karl does here's
his number it's not enough that the
characters are nerdy on their own they
also have to wear near gear to doubly
ensure the viewer knows that the Nerds
one of whom even calls himself specs our
nerds
inexplicably loud heartbeat noise to
build suspense cliche it's just not fun
anymore
why would the demon worry about placing
the hidden not hidden camera just so in
the closet creating this drawn-out
moment of suspense did he want to give
himself enough time to slowly walk
around the room again
so why would the demon who has now
possessed her break the casts off what
does this accomplish is now harder for
him/her to walk around if anything it
makes him easier to capture and tie up
very useless being father are we sure
this is the demon talking and now specks
who is suddenly no longer in shock or
affected by being hit across the face by
a wrench snaps into action to help Shawn
wrestle his daughter to the bed while
Tucker who was kicked in the leg is
still lying on the ground in agony and
where did her brother come from was he
in his room how did he not hear any of
the commotion until this moment gosh
he's late for everything and Elise
creeps in during all the moving around I
would kick her out too cuz it seems like
something terrible happens every time
she shows up it's a spirit who used to
live in this building a long time ago
what's the over-under on her making all
this up it's not like she's had any time
between causing problems and not wanting
to do this anymore to read up on the
deaths inside of this particular
building after the accident it got half
her soul how do you grab half a soul
typing would be faster yes yes could you
just maybe write it down and try not to
talk are they trying to inject some
humor right here because I find most of
this distracting also what is recording
any of it gonna do except help these
guys with their webseries take it for me
anyone with a webseries is not worthy of
being helped made you kill yourself what
happened between the Chinese restaurant
and now that made her know everything
you're free now free isn't she's still
in the further or are we talking about
free from the rainy nook downstairs
nothing really seems like it's going
well for this dead girl this is how you
died
not today it is always make sure to
study the philosophy of Syrio Forel
before attempting any exercise um's come
on bitch if that's really all it took
then why didn't she just call her a
bitch in the first movie she could have
avoided the whole also being dead dick
and she gets real off-track real quick
how long before she tells him she can't
do this anymore but I know that my Jack
would never ask me to do this I also
know that your Jack would never be
caught dead without his awesome sweater
vest and I am very strong so here's a
shove take that demon moves a bunch of
furniture around but apparently can't
block the exit I don't want to rain on
Lisa's parade or anything but he seems
to be more powerful at shoving than she
does it's got her Li's didn't stay
behind to make sure she got the job done
and now she's not in the further she's
back into here I guess a queen is still
gone if Carl were here none of this
would happen Lily waits to show up into
the very last second because of this
letter when it seems like she could have
just shown up at any time making her own
family go through all this mental and
physical anguish probably need that mask
to breathe when you're a demon in the
afterlife don't get so Lily was there
while the demon was also there so it
seems like Lily would have been aware of
everything that was happening with her
daughter but chose not to step in until
now
thanks parenting Lily she's never coming
back again no Quinn that's how death
works also bummer her brother missed out
on the messages of love from beyond the
grave
good job good job at doing nothing cuz
they did absolutely nothing you boys
fight too much did they really need to
throw in this manufacturer disingenuous
banter has to be a better way for them
to set up a sequel I mean a third sequel
I'm pretty sure that dog has been in the
bed for weeks I'm jealous I love you too
jack
but Jack didn't lay out the sweater it
was the final jump-scare also what the
hell does this even mean she apparently
totally forgets about this by the time
the first insidious rolls around we know
this demon doesn't do anything to her
after this so what a bunch of bull
you
play with us come play with this tank I
can hear someone my mom can I hear them
I hear them in the morning I hear them
in the evening they're coming into the
shower Sam what the hell did you do to
me did you tell every spook in the world
you met about me
I got spooks which are Z coming in here
wait Master it might be dangerous
you got fast something strange in baby
food hey Alex
what standing right next to you what are
you talking about
you
morning thank you for coming my name is
dr. Victor read over the past 10 years I
put together a state-of-the-art research
facility in order to study and implement
groundbreaking genetic and biological
experiments I'm here to report that on
December 2nd Elizabeth was born to my
knowledge she is the first human clone
it's what we haven't prepared for that I
always worried about this is just the
beginning isn't it tell you the truth I
don't know I never stopped
we are on the break of a new human
evolution